هذه هي اللحظة التي عثرت فيها سارة ليندغرين،
مديرة حديقة بنسلفانيا، على
شبل دب في ورطة وتحركت
[موسيقى] هيا
يا
لينغرين تقول إنها اعتقدت أن هذا الشبل قد
مات عندما اقتربت منه لأول مرة في
منطقة نائية
لم يكن لديها خدمة خلوية  لذلك عندما
بدا أن الدب يتحرك
إلى تجربتها في الحياة البرية لإنقاذه،
أوه، ها
أنت ذا، لا بأس، اعتقدت لينغرين أن
الدب كان في خطر داهم،
وقالت لشبكة CNN إنه يبدو أن
عمره ثمانية أشهر تقريبًا وكانت قلقة من
احتمال تعرضه للضرب  بواسطة سيارة غرقت في
الجدول أدناه أو ماتت بسبب
الجفاف في غضون يوم واحد
بعد عملية الإنقاذ، تسلق الشبل
شجرة للتعافي بينما
يقول الزوجان لينغرين الحاد وغير المؤذي أنه يجب عليك
دائمًا الاتصال بسلطات الولاية في
حالة حدوث حالات طوارئ للحياة البرية